ja also ich möchte wirklich über die
frage reden was machen wir in
deutschland und was machen wir falsch
meine während in vielen anderen
europäischen ländern offenbar ein
anderes virus kursiert weil dort mit
blick auf oregon mittlerweile die
pandemie für beendet erklärt wurde
nahezu alle maßnahmen aufgehoben wurden
oder zumindest beschlüsse gefasst wurden
lockern wir im schneckentempo und
natürlich wird gesagt ja bis 20 märz
sind die maßnahmen weg aber für junge
leute ist es halt bitter wenn sie nach
wie vor zum beispiel wenn sie nicht
geimpften nicht in clubs und diskotheken
dürfen es ist für familien ein problem
dass sie nach wie vor in der situation
sind bei hochzeiten beerdigungen ihre
nicht geimpften verwandten und bekannten
aus laden zu müssen und die frage ist ja
wozu das alles und ich höre dann immer
herrn scholz oder auch ein lauterbach
die sagen ja das alles hat uns sozusagen
hat dazu geführt dass wir sehr gut durch
die pandemie gekommen sind dass wir
besser sind als andere länder ich habe
mir vor kurzem mal angeguckt die zahlen
wie viele menschen an und mit corona
gestorben sind in den letzten drei
monaten und da war ich echt verblüfft
weil es ist tatsächlich so deutschland
hat die restriktivsten maßnahmen
trotzdem sind bei uns relativ viele
menschen gestorben übrigens sogar mehr
als in großbritannien wo die impfquote
eher niedriger ist als bei uns wo gar
keine maßnahmen mehr waren und natürlich
auch mehr als in den meisten anderen
ländern und wenn ich dann immer höre ja
das liegt an der großen brücke muss man
auch sagen es gibt kaum ein land in
europa dass in einem solchen daten
blindflug durch die ganze pandemie
rauscht wir wissen ja noch nicht mal
genau wie viele menschen geimpft sind
das rk ii sagt wahrscheinlich fünf
prozent mehr als im dschungel gemeldet
wurden das heißt bei den variablen bei
den älteren wären das dann 93% wir
wissen natürlich in deutschland auch
nicht wie viele chinesen sind weil wir
das auch nicht messen wir wissen bis
heute nicht wie viele wirklich weg in
corona in den krankenhäusern liegen
trotzdem wird das alles als argument
benutzt neben einschränkungen aufrecht
zu erhalten und eine einschränkung eine
ganz gravierende die soll sogar über den
20 märz hinaus aufrechterhalten bleiben
und das ist die einrichtung bezogene
impfpflicht und da muss ich ehrlich
sagen das finde ich wirklich ein hören
wie man hier mit pflegerinnen und
pflegern umgeht und ihnen den stuhl
quasi vor die tür stellen will menschen
die sich jetzt zwei jahre um andere
gekümmert haben die menschen gepflegt
haben auch als es noch gar keine impfung
gab die wahrscheinlich auch alle
vermutlich die infektion schon hinter
sich haben und das einzige argument was
da immer angeführt wird und das ist ja
das womit auch das gesetz begründet
wurde ja wir müssen die bullen haben
schützen aber alle seriösen virologen
herrscht rege stört alle anderen sagen
die impfung schützt gar nicht davor dass
ich mich infiziere und andere anstecken
und wir sehen das ja auch wir haben ja
teilweise in den ländern mit den
höchsten impfquoten die höchsten
instanzen aber wenn die impfung gar
nicht davor schützt dass sich andere
anstecken kann dann muss ich sagen ist
doch diese einrichtung bezogene
impfpflicht für pflegerinnen und pfleger
eine ganz absurde maßnahme die nur den
pflegenotstand verstärkt die den auch
wenn sie jetzt nicht direkt umgesetzt
wird das weiß man ja noch nicht genau
die den pflegerinnen und pflegern ein
damoklesschwert über den kopf hängt und
die natürlich junge leute vielleicht
auch davon abhält noch mehr abhält sich
für diesen beruf ausbilden zu lassen ich
finde das ist der völlig falsche weg und
ich finde man muss dringend darüber
nachdenken solche unsinnigen gesetze
zurück zu nehmen und auf keinen fall auf
diesem weg weiter zu gehen also über
frau wagenknecht erstmal ist ja eines
völlig klar ist ist eine gute situation
mit blick auf die zahlen wir laufen auf
einem datum zu nämlich den zwanzigster
märz wo ganz wesentliche maßnahmen
aufgehoben werden und das ist genau der
richtige weg denn wir haben so viele
freiheits einschränkungen gehabt in der
pandemie dass die menschen oft man jetzt
mehr unter diesen freiheitseinschränkung
gelitten haben als unter einer konkreten
infektion ich erinnere an die situation
in den familien an die situation der
kinder an häusliche gewalt und die
verwahrlosung der innenstadt all das
große probleme wir brauchten scharfe
maßnahmen aber jetzt ist auch der
richtige moment gekommen um sie
aufzugeben aber mit blick auf die
einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht und
der blick auf die frage reicht die
impfquote aus um auch im nächsten herbst
auch im nächsten winter freiheits
einschränkungen mich haben zu können da
muss man ganz klar sagen wir es gut
gewesen wenn nicht sie unter anderem
auch so große zweifel gestreut hätten an
der impfung hätten sich vielleicht auch
mehr pflegerinnen und pfleger impfen
lassen und wir hätten jetzt nicht so
eine situation also ein bisschen mehr
werbung für die impfung bisschen mehr
zuversicht und vertrauen ihm diese
wirksam das hier verboten
naja ich gesagt also dass sich zweifel
an der impfung gesät habe ich habe immer
dafür geworben dass sich ältere menschen
impfen lassen aber erst pflegerinnen und
pfleger die in medizinischen berufen
arbeiten sich aus ihr urteil davon
abhängig machen ob ich mich impfen lasse
oder was ich öffentlich sage das halte
ich für ein bisschen absurd ich bekomme
ja auch ganz viel resonanz von menschen
die sich gegen die impfung entscheiden
und da gibt es meistens sehr plausible
gründe das sind zum beispiel menschen
die haben die erstimpfung nicht
vertragen und die sagen da möchte ich
keine zweite oder es sind menschen die
im unmittelbaren umkreis oder auch in
den pflegeheimen gesehen haben dass
menschen doch auch durch die impfung zu
schaden kommen können was es ja auch
gibt das wird ja gar nicht bestritten
oder es sind eben auch menschen die wie
ich bin jung ich bin gesund also warum
soll ich mich impfen lassen und wenn das
hauptargument wegfällt und da stimmen
sie mir hoffentlich zu weit ist ja
wirklich inzwischen wieder
wissenschaftlich widerlegt ist dass
ungeimpfte pfleger andere gefährden dann
ist ja doch gibt es doch gar keinen
grund warum der staat jetzt sagen soll
weil weil sie in der pflege arbeiten
müssen sie sich impfen lassen also sie
entscheiden doch dann nur über ihre
eigene gesundheit und nicht darüber ob
sie andere gefährden und nur die
gefährdung anderer wäre für mich ein
plausibles argument bei der masern
impfen ich zum beispiel dass man sagt
also die die geimpft sind die können
niemanden mehr anstecken das wäre
tatsächlich ein gewichtiger grund zu
sagen dann sollte man das sein lassen
aber das ist nicht so und was sich auch
in höheren finde das ist zum beispiel
warum hier kein schutz wirklich nach wie
vor realisiert wird warum wird nicht in
den pflegeheimen und krankenhäusern bis
heute nicht systematisch getestet die
stiftung patientenschutz hat jetzt noch
einmal laut öffentlich dass eingefordert
weil schon wieder in ein pflegeheim
sechs alte menschen gestorben sind alle
gepostet weil das weil das virus
reingekommen ist testen in diesen
bereichen das wäre wichtig aber nicht
pflegerinnen und pfleger quasi
rauszuschmeißen und nicht weiter ihren
beruf ausüben zuletzt 1 akzeptiere ich
nicht und das ist dass die impfung
dargestellt wird als die fortsetzung der
freiheitsbeschränkungen der pandemie die
impfung ist der weg aus den
freiheitsbeschränkungen der pandemie
heraus und das gilt auch im besitz
natürlich ist es nein die begründung
einer der gründe für die einrichtung war
das der verleger aber ihren patienten
nicht anstecken kann in dem moment wo er
zwar weniger infektiös ist aber die
patienten doch ansteckt entfällt dieses
argument und da hat frau warte nicht
völlig recht dass testen wäre sehr viel
effizienter wenn man dann weiß innerhalb
einer schicht kann ein pfleger der sie
frühmorgens hat testen lassen und
negativ war zwar auch infektiös werden
aber erst wenn er nicht geimpft ist es
sogar noch kurioser wenn er nicht
geimpft ist spürt er möglicherweise
heftigere symptome und weiß schneller
dass er infiziert ist als wenn er sich
in falscher sicherheit wiegt ist
gepustet und hat die den virus auf der
schulter so ganz wichtig das testen in
alten- und pflegeheim muss
flächendeckend erfolgen ich bin froh
dass wir das auf den weg gebracht haben
wenn das noch nicht flächendeckend
erfolg ich sagen muss sofort kommen das
bringt auch viel mehr als eine impfung
bei der wie sie richtig sagen die
ansteckungsgefahr noch gegeben ist aber
sie haben ja gerade selber gesagt die
leute sind weniger infektions haben denn
die haben andere situation haben
doch das gibt es ganz kurz sagen dass
auch pfleger eine situation erleiden in
der sie krank werden dann am ende
langzeitschäden von corona davon tragen
dann ist es wichtig auch in diesem
bereich die den pflegenotstand zu
bekämpfen
hierzu sorgen wollen dass die leute
gehen jetzt mit großem interesse und mir
fällt auf sehen wenn nicht das große
fehlverhalten der politik hier auch
wieder unter brennglas also testen wäre
die beste lösung haben wir doch
eingeführt ja auch in der ich will was
sagen aber wir kriegen es nicht gebacken
es wird sozusagen getestet und deshalb
werden andere menschen gezwungen sich
impfen zu lassen oder sie verlieren den
job das ist ja das ist das nicht und ich
sehe darin nicht resignieren herrliche
sein gesundes organ steht in serie doch
inhaber hat er genau dass eingeführt und
in alten- und pflegeheim flächendeckend
getestet also da müssen wir uns noch mal
informieren aber ich halte es für
absolut richtig das zu machen das
gegeneinander auszuspielen wir werden
sie denn das ist der fall wenn sie denn
dann der film entdeckt man hat überall
flächendeckend test dass man dann
ungeimpfte pfleger und und
krankenschwestern trotzdem die
möglichkeit gibt dazu arbeiten ich bin
dafür dass sich alle krankenpfleger und
alle krankenschwestern impfen lassen
wenn sie darauf
wenn sie daraus eine situation ergibt
das ein pflegeheim schließen muss oder
wie eine situation haben wo leute nicht
mehr betreut werden können dann muss das
in den ländern gelöst werden aber ich
akzeptiere nicht dass ausgerechnet leute
wie herr kretzschmar oder leute wie herr
söder die der ganz die die ganze zeit
der ampel anweisungen geben wollen jetzt
ausgerechnet sagen
reinbringen bevor wir uns wieder in
prien zirkus verlieren ob sie jetzt
markus söder gut fällt oder die anderen
als bürgerin interessiert mich das gar
nicht mehr der entfalten mich
interessiert jetzt die einrichtungs
bezogen pflicht da habe ich eine frage
zu studien legen nahe dass 90 prozent
der pflegekräfte längst geimpft sind
warum also muss man jetzt bis zum
letzten alle zwingen und dann damit
lebensträume zerstören weil wir immer
noch konstellationen haben in denen
leute corona bekommen und dann schwere
langzeit folgen davontragen und dann
nicht mehr im gesundheitssystem arbeiten
können also haben sie auch eine
verschlimmerung des pflege luft also
sich meisten die lieber vorher raus sein
und leute eigentlich leichen klären
warum nicht vorher genau das ist das was
ich ihnen vorwerfen sie spät sie
politisieren diese impfung in einer
weise die an meinen dass ich will doch
einfach nur dass jeder der arbeiten kann
nix das sage ich auch ganz bewusst der
dazu beiträgt dass wir endlich aus
diesem freiheitsbeschränkungen rauskommt
ich will keine locker und maßnahmen ja
ich will keine schulschließung mehr ich
will dass die leute ins theater gehen
können ich will dass die leute wieder
ihre klage auf machen also ich meine
dabei hat heute auf jeden fall helfen ja
aber bei amazon gibt es doch für all
diese maßnahmen überhaupt keine
grundlage mehr ausliegen leute ja auch
jetzt zwanzigsten mal raus aus dieser
nicht sagen sie wollen jetzt ein pfleger
sich und aber ich lebe nun damit dass
nur es läuft das eine hat mit dem
anderen nichts zu tun ich bin ja auch
durchaus der meinung dass es bei älteren
menschen oder mit bestimmten
vorerkrankungen
das ist sinnvoll und ein schutz ist wenn
sie sich impfen pflegerinnen und pfleger
sind meistens eher nicht so ältere
menschen weil er körperlich harter beruf
und meistens vielleicht auch nicht mit
den unbedingten vorerkrankungen vor
allem sind viele auch wahrscheinlich
genesen also die haben das hinter sich
diesen besser geschützt als die
geimpften so und jetzt kommt der staat
und sagt also diese berufsgruppe da
gehen wir jetzt hin und sagen ihr müsst
euch impfen verpflichtend sonst habe der
berufsverbot dafür gab es noch 1 auch
der miliz ja auch studenten und als ich
meine auch bei zahnarztpraxen und
ähnlichen das ist ja ziemlich weit es
geht ja bis hin zur cafeteria im
krankenhaus und das ohne die
wissenschaftliche grundlage die
rechtfertigen würde zu sagen man schützt
damit jemand sie haben jetzt auch gesagt
nicht nur schranken schließen werden
geschichten oder geben die infektiosität
ist vermindert auch bei omikron
verschärfung ich habe vor kurzem ein
video gesehen von herrn strikt da hatte
das ganz klar geschildert hat wir sollen
also zweifach geimpft das sind gar nicht
geschützt bei der booster impfung ist es
so dass es maximal drei monate die
infektiosität verringert das schon und
danach ist es wieder genauso wie bei
ungeimpften das heißt konsequenterweise
müssten sie die pflegekräfte
verpflichten sich alle drei monate
ostern zu lassen und glaube ich kann das
kein ernst zu nehmender mensch vertreten
aber nur dann hätten sie tatsächlich
einen gewissen infektionsschutz also ich
glaube wir haben wir sind dadurch dass
wir es impfung nennen haben wir einen
qualitätsanspruch an eine impfung die
mental davon ausgeht die krankheit wird
abgeschaltet wie ähnlich wie es bei
anderen impfungen ist das passiert hier
nicht dann hätte sonst hätte ich
verständnis dafür also wenn es eine
gelbfieberimpfung wäre 98% kriege ich
die krankheit nicht würde ich sagen gut
könnten wir darüber reden so sehe ich
das nicht das andere ist wenn sie ein
gesetz beschließen in der ampel und dann
gibt es die ausführungsbestimmungen
nicht wer bitte schön soll denn im
pflegeheim die impf nachweise einsammeln
wer weiß was zu tun ist wenn jemand sagt
zeige ich dir nicht was passiert wenn
derjenige sagt ich kann ja in der
zwischenzeit als hausmeister unten
arbeiten pflege ich halt nicht mehr
darauf der bleiben darf man nicht da
bleiben wenn er nicht da bleiben darf
kriegt der arbeitslosengeld 1 gericht
arbeitslosengeld 2 es ist nichts
geregelt ich meine die ampel beschließt
so was das gesundheitsministerium müsste
die ausführungsbestimmungen machen
liefert nicht und dann sollen die länder
irgendwie gucken ja das gesundheitsamt
wird schon irgendwas finden dann fängt
jedes gesundheitsamt in einer region an
der regel zu machen ist völlig irre also
dann wenn es so ein herzensanliegen ist
dann bitte aber auch liefern also ein
herzensanliegen das ist ganz bestimmt
nicht aber es ist ein weg der dazu
führen wird hoffentlich dass wir im
nächsten herbst und im nächsten winter
keine so weitreichenden
freiheitsbeschränkungen haben wir leben
das ist eigentlich ganz gut
in der demokratie was schönes ich glaube
dass man auch den fokus weiten muss und
sagen muss erschreckenderweise haben ja
heute stolz unser kanzler hat gesagt
dass er sich mit 16 ministerpräsidenten
einig weiß dass die impfpflicht für alle
also die allgemeine impfpflicht
sozusagen auch kommen soll also das
bedeutet diese im fetisch als der staat
legt fest dass sich alle irgendwie
impfen lassen müssen er ist nicht vom
tisch das ist das gegenteil von freedom
day das ist quasi weiter die anmaßung in
die persönliche entscheidung von
menschen massiv einzugreifen aber ich
habe ich selbst ehrlich natürlich die
hand eine wissenslücke sie wollen auch
das alles gegeben für das ich würde mir
wünschen dass man sich impfen lassen ich
traue den leuten aber zügig mit den
argumenten auseinanderzusetzen deswegen
soll die sich beraten lassen und dann
gucken werden die bereits in zwei jahren
genau die beratungs variant und dann
gucken wir mal im september ob wir
wirklich eine impfpflicht brauchen und
sandro wenn du dich nicht beraten lässt
ja vielleicht sogar ein zusammenhang
klar machen zwischen den zwischen der
abwesenheit von freiheitsbeschränkungen
und der impfung ich habe das gerade
schon gesagt ich will keine neuen
maßnahmen man muss jetzt auch mal durch
hättest du nie geben dürfen ich verstehe
diese verbindung nicht man muss doch
jetzt eher mal recherchieren ob wir
jemals die schulen hätten schließen
dürfen aber ist jeweils notwendig
erschien dann lassen sie uns das
recherchieren das müssen wir machen aber
wir müssen auch verhindern und da haben
wir glaube ich wirklich den eindruck
haben viele leute überhaupt keinen bock
drauf dass wir im september oktober 2022
wieder an derselben stelle stehen wie im
letzten jahr
ich meine mit omikron ist zunächst mal
nicht damit zu rechnen wenn das virus
auf der ebene bleibt die omikron also
was die krankheit schwerer angeht dann
sehen wir doch jetzt wir haben aktuell
weniger patienten mit corona in den
intensivstationen als wir wahrscheinlich
sonst um diese jahreszeit
grippepatienten in den intensivstationen
hatten oder haben sich das land dem
ausklammern den lockdown geschickt so
jetzt weiß man nicht herr lauterbach ist
ja da immer dabei uns ganz schlimme
große mutanten vorherzusagen keiner weiß
es also natürlich kann das theoretisch
passieren dass das virus mutiert und
auch wieder schwerer schwerwiegender
wird aber was ziemlich sicher ist wenn
es weiter mutiert dann ist das eben so
eine flucht mutter die omikron das heißt
weil sonst kann sich ja gar nicht so gut
verbreiten das heißt das ist dann eine
mutante die sowohl die genesenen als
auch die geimpften wieder infizieren da
brauchen wir neue impfstoffe das ist
einfach falsch wenn sie den leuten
weismachen wenn jetzt ganz viele sich
impfen die impfung hat jetzt für die
delta variante geschützt und bei omikron
auch noch so einigermaßen da ist es
schon schwächer da ist es schon viel
schwächer da ist nur zum glück so dass
die oregon variante nicht gefährlich ist
aber es ist völlig absurd so zu tun dass
jetzt die impfung für den herbst
vorbereitet das wissen wir nicht also
erstmal sehen wir dass die impfung nach
einer gewissen zeit ihren impfschutz
auch verliert also der schutz lässt nach
das ist so und das zweite ist eben wenn
dann neue mutationen kommen dann muss
man vielleicht auch eine neue impfung
haben das heißt die leute jetzt zu
verpflichten heißt noch lange nicht dass
der herbst entspannt wird ich hoffe
allerdings dass die virologen recht
haben die sagen es ist sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass nochmal schwerere
varianten